soy diseñador gráfico publicista
fotógrafo y ahora me metí de lleno en un
proyecto de un río y me metí desde
muchos ángulos
río al revés o ir al derecho es reír y
me metí tanto tanto que hasta cuando
trotaba me encontraba con imágenes de
este estilo y me preguntaba por qué
diablos porque no existía ningún una
imagen de peces en la parte urbana y
rural del río otún
empecé pues a pensar y llegué a la
conclusión que probablemente pensamos
que esa agua está tan contaminada que no
hay existe posibilidad de que haya vida
alguna jim o podemos simplemente con un
servicio utilitario
entonces empecé
a investigar y un día me encontré con
esta imagen aquí quiero parar un segundo
y le pregunta si notan algo extraño en
esta imagen
una pista para los que no lo han visto
fue un 20 de julio exactamente la
bandera está al revés
esto probablemente no pase de ser pues
una colombiana da o algo así pero para
mí lo peor lo peor lo peor es que yo no
hice nada
el otro día
observé cómo esta persona venía a prisa
hacia una bonita pintura y dije por un
segundo que verdad es que era una
persona que está apreciando el arte al
siguiente segundo y ante la mirada
atónita de estos venados esta era su
prisa
'mea culpa'
la falta de cultura también va conmigo
me levanté el sofá y me dediqué a crear
les presento a darío del río darío es un
pez muy valiente muy valiente que
regresa al sitio donde nació de donde
los echamos viene con su esposa
esperanza y su hijo de nacimiento y
regresan portando una pancarta con un
mensaje sencillo y muy contundente
queremos volver
teníamos que hacer un proyecto que
impactará y que tuviera mucho
kilometraje y aquí nace el proyecto ajo
avenida del río el acuario más
pintoresco del mundo
es un proyecto de innovación social de
carácter incluyente participativo y
estético me fui pues a maletear estas
ideas de un lado para otro hasta que por
fin logré un patrocinio y salió en la
prensa y esto ya empezó a generar ruido
mucha expectativa y por esos días conocí
a dos artistas espectaculares a álvaro
ellos ya bibiana ángel
juntos hicimos clic de inmediato y nos
lanzamos al agua
empezamos con un taller de mosaico y
cuando tú ves estas estas expresiones tú
te das cuenta que algo muy muy
importante está sucediendo y después nos
fuimos al frente hicimos una escultura a
la que llamamos banca de peces esta en
particular se llamaba banca de peces
corazón de arriba y lo interesante aquí
es que cuando empezamos esto está
completamente lleno de llantas a la
medida porque había un tipo que tenía un
taller en la esquina y a medida que
fuimos avanzando había menos llantas y
al final ya no existía ni una y este
personaje se convirtió en el fan número
uno de estas esculturas hasta punto que
lo me visto limpiando la y también
diciéndole a la gente parce tranquilo a
ese toma de la foto que yo cuido el
carro
luego pasamos al otro lado de la cuadra
y existía este espacio absolutamente
descuidado y maloliente y pensábamos que
hacer entonces limpiamos arreglamos e
invitamos a los niños empezamos a pintar
ya sembrar unas matas de forma creativa
y este es el resultado terminamos en una
plazoleta y aquí nace darío de río y su
familia
esto alguien en una publicación
recientemente donde alguien comentaba
que su papá había atrapado un pez la
zabaleta en la calle 18 donde nadie se
esperaba que pudiese vivir un pez y toda
la gente empezó a hacer comentarios y
entre otras él agradecía a estos
proyectos de esas casitas pintadas y al
proyecto queremos volver probablemente
es ley de atracción estos proyectos
tienen la capacidad de sorprenderlo a
uno de muchas maneras un día estaba
tranquilo después de la inauguración de
la primera fase y llegó una persona y me
dice usted de sacar velasco
yo le dije depende y me dijo que quería
que hiciéramos algo muy similar a lo que
se había hecho en el otro lado yo dije
qué pena hermano porque ya se nos acabó
el presupuesto y me dijo que es un 9 era
lo que era importante que lo que
necesitaban era que estuviéramos ahí y
así fue y me fui comí pica y esperamos
no sé yo esperaba que llegaran 234
personas pero al final aparecieron 28
personas para ayudar entre contando
mujeres y niños y entre todos arreglamos
este este sitio quedó muy bonito
luego ya está este proyecto pues que era
el colmo yo no le podía dar crédito que
en un sitio y existiera tanto desorden
especialmente al lado de una estación de
policía entonces pensamos que hacer aquí
necesitamos una especie de guía algo que
nos que nos generará digamos que nos
devolverá la confianza que nos mostrará
el camino y no precisamente ahora puedes
hacer aquí un jesucristo o algo por el
estilo y aquí terminamos haciendo el
único faro del mundo
con cortinas rosadas
y
existía cierto problema entre algunos
vecinos y la estación de policía del
sitio y nos preguntábamos qué hacer cómo
podíamos reconectar los entonces en mi
vida había hablado con un mayor de la
policía y mucho menos con mayor de una
estación de antidisturbios y suma fama
pues de malas pulgas
le pregunté mayor este mes a pintar hay
un cocodrilo y el mayor dijo un
cocodrilo donde yo le dije ahí ahí le
mostré el boceto se atacó en la risa y
me dijo hagámoslo dice qué palabra tan
bonita
hagámoslo y así fue empezamos a pintar
con niños de la cuadra y así nació este
sonriente cocodrilo que aparte de una
gran sonrisa nos muestra un poco la
rigidez de digamos que desde su piel y
lo que comunica un poco lo que es
realidad a una policía antidisturbios
luego regreso unos meses después me
encontré con esto casi todo lo que
habíamos hecho estaba destruido
y en un momento en esta nación una obra
necesaria en algún momento de mi derecho
al carajo con esto no vuelvo a hacer
nada pero estamos como estamos y alegar
contra todo el mundo con esta ocasión
dije aquí hay piedras a mí me fascina la
estética de las piedras de arriba de
hecho esto era un lecho del río en algún
momento entonces dije por favor wards de
mesas piedras para que se van a encantar
con las piedras por favor guarden velas
que la necesito
al final tenía una montaña gigantesca de
piedras y ha pensado y ahora que voy a
hacer que encarta
pero por fortuna por esos días apareció
reapareció un amigo que nos ayudó en la
primera fase en artista y le dije
esquivo robert ahora tenemos esta
montaña de piedras para soñar que
hacemos porque estamos pelados usted me
dijo empezamos a pensar que íbamos a
hacer y me dijo no yo me voy a ir a
inspirar al río
bueno lo espere de regreso y medio que
se ha encontrado con una iguana gigante
y que se habían quedado conversando y
pues por qué no entonces
entonces yo le dije listo haga mole y
empezamos a trabajar ya trabajar digamos
que los vecinos empezaron a
impacientarse porque veían que no
avanzaba pero estamos avanzando a la
velocidad pues del bolsillo incluso un
periódico escribe un titular que decía
una obra que se convirtió en en cartel
y están cada vez y duros con estas
piedras y avanzamos y avanzamos no fue
hasta que roberto hizo la cabeza que la
gente ya he jugado y se enamoraron de
esta iguana y ya se convirtió en una
especie de icono de la ciudad
luego nos queríamos ya salir de esa de
esa cuadra pero no queríamos irnos sin
antes dejar un poco de vida en esta
cuadra está demasiado apagada terminamos
pintando las casas de colores bonitos
hicimos un mural que tiene mucho
significado dice un río un nido
un pájaro alimentando a un pez en su
nido
y avanzamos una empresa nos dijo que nos
gustaría hacer un proyecto que uniera
unas comunidades que no pues que no se
quiera mucho entre sí como eso que
llaman las fronteras invisibles entonces
le dije bueno vamos a hacer vamos a
trabajar aquí una vamos a conectarse es
un puente que mejor forma de contar este
cuento que un puente un puente nos debe
conectar y así fue hicimos un taller en
mosaico con todo incluso los dos lados
lo hicimos unidos y terminamos haciendo
un puente morito puente en el puente
gaitán y luego siguen apareciendo más
peces y más peces aquí apareció un
personaje llamado nut o montaba en
bicicleta después la buena vibra del río
y está rodeado de peces que nos están
mostrando nuestro destino estamos
haciendo bancas de muchas clases este en
particular está hecha en forma de
meandros y tiene una materia al lado
para que nos podamos sentar a conversar
con la mata del lado o la margarita como
éstas o la vera negra como estas en este
caso y empezamos a trabajar otro otro
tema en sitios donde hay muchas muchas
escombros basura pero estamos en una
jardín es pero no es cualquier clase de
jardines son los jardines buffet
y si yo veo una abeja o una mariposa un
pájaro me encantaría llegar a un sitio
donde pudiera probar miles de mieles
24/7 barra abierta solamente necesito
polinizar y lo más bonito bajo el lema
para todos hay miel y eso es un sitio
donde las mariposas nos cuentan a la
velocidad que debemos ir donde hay otro
hay una caracola
encaramado en una señalética donde están
pues los sitios de interés de la zona y
al otro lado los bonitos pájaros del
lugar quien no ha sufrido cuando ven a
un animal a una lagartija oa una chucha
tratando de cruzar una vía un armadillo
amarillo incomodando nos un poquito
nuestro caminar nos hace recordar que
todos los seres ocupamos el mismo
espacio los peces nos cuentan por dónde
cruzar las abejas nos enseñan a trabajar
en grupo una una sirena y todos sabemos
cómo donde complicadas nos están dando
la bienvenida a este malecón y nos
invita a sentarnos junto a ella
m
donde no había ni un solo pez ahora
existen ciento cientos de ellos de
formas fantásticas y reales y por ahí
siempre verán nada darío nadando
un día un personaje nos preguntó hasta
dónde me lleva este barco y estamos
terminando de hacer un barquito de papel
en origami que le llamamos río ramis y
le dije hasta donde usted quiera llegar
seguimos conversando y me contó times 3
tan fantásticas tan fantásticas que me
di cuenta que este en realidad es el
gran atún
la naturaleza las matas el agua las
abejas todo el tiempo nos están
conversando este personaje por ejemplo
mientras estaba esperando plácidamente
sentado al lado del río le salió arma
están sucediendo grandes cambios
están sucediendo muchísimos cambios y
nos estamos recolectando muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]